[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show george camel
ramsey personality is my co-host today
he's also the host of the ever popular
fine print podcast right there on ramsey
networks and millions of you have tuned
into that thank you very very much
today we're going to be talking to you
about your work we're going to be
talking to you about your relationships
and we're going to be talking to you
about your money and we're talking to
you about you right in front of you open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five george is in new york
city to start off this hour hey george
what's up
hey how are you it's great to talk with
you you too man how can i help
i'm calling because i'm struggling with
figuring out how to balance growing a
business i recently started while also
doing a lot of the home care with my two
young children the third kid on the way
and probably needing to pay for some
child care i'm trying to get out of
about 225 000 of debt with my wife and
we're having a hard time figuring out
how to do that quickly and efficiently
with um without my having more time to
grow the business
okay
what kind of debt
a lot of student loan debt a lot of
mistakes and uh paying way too much for
school i'm a psychologist and i spent
over three hundred thousand dollars to
become a psychologist um
and uh so
i think you say a lot of stupid uh i've
heard you say before yeah what's your
business you open a practice also i did
i i for a long time was going to do the
public service loan forgiveness but uh
you you all were part of my inspiration
to decide not to do that and uh to pay
back what i borrowed i paid back my wife
and i have paid back over a hundred
thousand dollars of that so far we have
225 left
well we inspire people to pay back what
you owe for one thing but it's also
important that we also give you
information the student loan forgiveness
is a complete fraud that only 4 000
people have actually gotten it while
almost 300 000 have applied for it so we
need to keep that in mind it wasn't
going to work so there's that but yeah
so way to go man you got a bot like you
got a lot of balls in there you're a
busy man
uh that's i appreciate you saying that
because it sure feels like it how's the
business doing
uh it's been fantastic thank you i feel
very fortunate that i've been able to do
that and without knowing much about
ken's proximity principle uh that's kind
of how i grew it and did it slowly and
then took a small step instead of a big
leap and it's doing very well i'm very
happy with it i'd like to help grow it
to be able to pay off the debt faster
but with myself my doing a lot of
cooking doing a lot of picking up kids
and getting here to there i feel like i
only have so much time and
okay because you know probably and why
are you doing all the child care
my wife also works
she's a school teacher and she provides
us our health benefits and she's an
amazing woman and i appreciate
everything she does but with the
flexibility i have with
my my schedule
that's where i'm kind of picking up and
so
that that's where the dilemma is
okay what will your business make this
year
uh revenue just the last at this last
year was just under 300 000 and what
does she make teaching school
she takes home uh
she makes a little over 70 uh she takes
home okay so the guy made the person
making 300 guy our gal
is taking time off from making 300
because the person making 70 doesn't
have time
correct
yeah that's real sweet but it's stupid
it's real nurturing but it's
economically stupid and it's part of why
you're stressed i mean and she's also
pregnant you said
and she we just found out we have our
third child on the way just found out
okay so first trimester well awesome man
it's exciting hey listen here's the
thing
uh none
you know
none of this lasts forever
and so when you're burning the candle at
both ends as long as it is not a 10-year
prescription you can get away with it
but you can't get away with it if
there's no hope that it's going to end
okay and christy wright talks about in
the book we did with her called take
back your time that balance is not doing
an equal amount of everything balance is
doing the right things
at the right time and so in this season
that you're in you've got to decide
here's what we're going to do
and in the next season we're going to do
x let me give an example okay i'm just
making this up this would happen at the
ramsey house as an example
we're old school though i'll warn you
ahead of time all right
um
sharon in the first trimester would take
on more of the kid's stuff and i'd i
would pour the i'd put the wood on the
fire over at work
by the time she gets the third trimester
she's gonna need some relief
for sure
and working okay and so yeah you're
gonna have to dial back work then and
step in as super dad again
but super dad right now
yeah
maybe not maybe not maybe maybe your
version of super dad right now is you
throw wood on the fire and get some is
paid down and then when the baby comes
you're probably going to slow down a
little bit too because she's got three
and she's going to be uh you know
recovering from delivery and so you got
about six you got about nine months
about the last three months of pregnancy
plus the next the first six months of
the new baby that you're going to be in
super dad mode and so you got to turn it
back and turn it turn it on turn it off
a little bit
um and just go this is for this season
and you two sit down talk about it
together she may not be willing to do
that but that's what sharon would do
and she would be going listen matter of
fact she would kick my butt out and go
get go get the work done you're the one
making money
she she didn't have any tolerance for
i mean we had rachel the year we filed
bankruptcy so i kind of stopped by the
hospital saw the baby went back to work
you know i mean it really wasn't like
rachel doesn't remember that yeah and
didn't affect rachel at all i mean
sharon but sharon's like old school
she's like what are you doing here
you're supposed to be working we need
money so uh yeah but that's uh uh but
it's a temporary thing i wasn't an
absentee dad the entire time my children
were there
but i really when i was starting the
business there was a time there was a
season
that i poured on the wood and then
there's a season that you have to be
there as a dad
more so like to help your wife in these
things and there's a season she has to
help yeah and
it's back and forth and back and forth
and then there's also a season where
it's just freaking crazy
and it's just not forever and we can
hold on by the skin of our teeth and
just grit our teeth and push through it
yeah i mean you guys are making 370
grand there's no reason you can't get
some child care get some help here so
that you can focus on work because
you're going to make more than you would
have if you were staying home taking
care of the kids versus putting them in
some kind of child care for this season
like dave saying and you can pay this
off in under two years with your income
this is easily possible but it feels
like a lot right now when you're
juggling it all at once but her throat
turned my trimester through the first
six months of the third child being born
your business is going to suffer because
you need to be there with your family
but this during the next six months um
your family is gonna they're gonna you
have to make some other adjustments
maybe i don't know that's one way you
could look at it the point being if
you'll take the pressure off of trying
to be everything to everyone all the
time and say okay for this season we're
gonna do this for this season we're
gonna do that for that season we're
gonna do this and then by the time when
all this is over here's what it's gonna
look like and we get to go to disney you
know
and or whatever it is you all do to
celebrate i didn't go to disney
celebrate but i did take the kids one
time after i was gone 60 days on a book
tour there we go that was a season i was
gone
128 media stops all over the united
states i was gone but it was the number
one got the got the career launch got
the book launch came home took the kids
to disney doesn't that's what they
remember don't they just stay they don't
put any noise gone
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
it is resolution
season and if you're like most people
you make resolutions on new year's day
and by valentine's day they're done if
you don't believe me look at the gym the
gym is empty by valentine's day
you can't find a machine to work out on
until valentine's day and then they're
all available if you've decided to
actually get control of your money let
me help you we want to walk with you way
past valentine's day
because it's going to take more than
valentine's day to get you there and
so you need to get into a financial
peace university class we'll walk you
through the proven
plan the proven process that about 7
million families about 10 million people
have been through
it works there's hundreds of financial
peace university classes getting started
right now in person and online
so don't do a lame-o resolution actually
set a goal there's a difference in a
goal and a resolution and get signed up
ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
that's ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu
george i want to revisit the last call
for a second and set some principles in
place
um
for everyone
out there
uh uh
the on this whole idea of work and
time balance
and being there for your family
okay
to start with we need to understand that
family
if you're around ramsey
is a
is of primary importance
having said that there are a lot of ways
you serve your family
one of them is making money
by working
and that's the way you serve your family
uh and
this idea that uh if you are
working and making money by definition
you are not nurturing or you are not
there for your family or your selfish is
not a true idea it's a falsehood
okay now completely abandoning your
family's emotional needs and spiritual
needs and psychological needs in the
name of work is not something we would
recommend family is primary as a matter
of fact one of our core values here is
family
at ramsay it's one of our 14 core values
family and it doesn't mean that we're
all family although we all treat each
other like family but
uh or the majority of us do but the uh
but we put family first
having said that
there is a
mindset that floats around out there in
the culture right now
that says
um
to the extent i work
i am abandoning my family and so if i
really pour on the coals to get out of
debt for six months or a year or two
years and i work five jobs
then i'm not a good dad i'm not a good
mom
and that is simply not true agreed oh
yeah and it's interesting because a lot
of the you know the call we had from
georgia new york city i i could tell his
struggle of i want to be a good dad but
i also feel like i need to provide for
the family but i don't want to be that
dad who abandons his family in the name
of work like you're talking about and i
don't see it as this either or either
you get to be a good dad or you get to
provide for your family you can do both
and they're gonna be in seasons and
while they're young like this i don't
remember anything from when i was three
years old if my dad was working a lot
but if you can get out of debt in these
two years while the kids are young and
you can be there for them for the rest
of their life that's a game changer
instead of being broke for the next 20
years in the name of being a good dad
and being there for them yeah my kids
and
in the ramsey family have traveled all
over the world with their dad and mom
have seen and done things
i never even dreamed i would do as a
little redneck kid growing up
much less get to do that for my kids and
for that matter now with their spouses
yeah and the grandkids the thing and now
the grandbabies we get to share
a lot of things and a lot of experiences
because of the price that was paid when
they were tiny exactly and living like
no one else so that later you can live
and give like no one else so we are not
anti-family but i also will not allow
you
in the marketplace to use
your
compassionate nurturing heart as an
excuse to not get your freaking work
done
because there's a season and during that
season you do what it takes
and the season is not forever
it's for a period of time you work like
no one else so that later you can work
like no one else
and you
uh uh you know and sometimes you know a
baby's on the way so you don't get to
work because you got to be there you got
two little kids and you know she's in
her third trimester she can't did she he
needs to be there for that yeah he needs
to be there he can't shut down his
entire practice but he doesn't need to
be working 80 hours over there she's
going to need the
logistical support in that household and
uh
but but the the there's this idea that
one means the other is not happening and
it is a both end
because you do it in seasons yeah and
you you know workaholism is you get your
identity from working
and so you work all the time forever
that's not a season that's an illness
and that's a misperception of work but
being afraid of hard work or avoiding
hard work because by definition that
means you're not a good dad or good mom
is also not a that's also a falsehood
yeah so the real balance is am i willing
to sacrifice for 18 months to get out of
225 000 in debt so that i can be there
for the next 18 years yeah that's that's
the trade or do we do
i mean we did some wacky stuff
while we were on the well where our back
was against the ball while we were at
rock bottom whatever metaphor we want to
use here right i mean we did some wacky
stuff to just survive
much less hoping to prosper in the
future
and uh
you know so you you there's some things
you're gonna do for a period of time
you're gonna put grad school on hold
till you get this done
and then you go back into it later
finish it later you're gonna uh
you know uh
not work
at the 70 000 job for two years while
the practice gets built and you raise
three little ones and then you go back
into the classroom maybe i'm not saying
that she has to and it's not a man or a
woman thing it's not a it's not a sexism
thing it's not anything to do with that
it's a simple trade of time for money
and
being present when you are home the
other thing you can do is you can work
like a maniac if you'll turn off the
television when you're home
and you'll actually be present in the
conversation put the phone down look
your kid in the eye when you're at home
yeah because most people you know they i
don't wanna wake me forty hours and then
they sit and watch hbo reruns while the
kids dancing around they don't even see
the kid
now that's that's asinine
that you said oh i'm you're not
nurturing you're an hbo addict
yeah maloney talks about this all the
time of hosing the boots off before you
walk in the door and really be present
for the kids yeah even if you're tired
take a moment to reset and it doesn't
take long no it doesn't take much i mean
you get emotional credit with kids
that is beyond belief
an example was we had a guy come talking
about parenting especially dads and
daughters one time at our church many
thousands of years ago my girls were a
little bitty he said take your daughters
on a date
get them all dressed up you get all
dressed up and go to a fancy place and
take them on a date you know get get a
rose you know do the whole thing have a
date night i thought hey i'm doing that
i'm doing that
if you ask rachel and denise we went on
dates through their whole childhood wow
in their minds this was happening all
the time five times maybe
wow maybe maybe 10. it stuck with them
but but you would think i got a lot of
credit that i didn't earn this was
weekly for 20 years that i didn't earn
yeah you know i really did because it
makes such
because you're actually not on the phone
you're not on email you're not got hbo
on you're not got a football game on in
the background you you're the you it's
just you and the little girl
and you're at this nice restaurant and
they don't even like the food yeah but i
did but they didn't and you know that
you know that yeah you get french fries
in a nice place you get a eye roll right
but get the kids menu but um yeah they
get the yeah but i mean that's
do that stuff because you get more
credit for it
than you earned
and uh but it's about intentionality and
it's about being present in the moment
hosing your boots off as deloney says
and um so i i i want you guys to have
permission to
for a season work like a maniac and not
walk around acting like you've done
something wrong
you didn't do anything wrong matter of
fact you did a lot of things right
in a culture where a lot of people don't
even know what hard work looks like
i mean let's face it when we work hard
in america it's kind of a joke oh yeah
compared to working hard around the
world
very few of us
really do hard hard work i mean i signed
like a thousand books the other day at
this book launch and they're like aren't
you tired and i'm like if i gripe about
this god's gonna make me do real work
you know oh that's good my wrist is
tired oh you know i mean come on i might
have to carry like a tray full of food
if i
whine about that right so that's like
real i'll make it do some real work yeah
i don't want to do real work
i used to used to cut grass i know what
real work is no thank you i don't want
to do real work
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you're looking for ways to update your
home without blowing the budget i've got
it for years i've been telling you about
our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in west hampton new jersey
alfred and aisha are with us to do their
debt-free scream according to my screen
what's up guys hey dave hi dave how are
you better than i deserve way to go how
much did you pay off 34 000 love it how
long did this take
took us about two years all right
your range of income during that time
and it was about a hundred thousand at
that point
and um but now that we are out of debt
we are up 35. oh so now you're at 135
what do y'all do for a living
i am an educator
and i auto detail love it love it cool
what kind of debt was the 34
lots of everything right bad decisions
david
[Laughter]
it was uh let's see a car loan credit
card student loans
you name it phone we didn't deserve yeah
okay cool
what was the uh what was the wake-up
call that started this two years ago
great question dave um actually
i was working in radio one of my
passions so thank you for having us here
today it's a completely crazy story but
i picked up one of your books and i
started reading it and i never even
thought about that at this point it
wasn't even a thought in my mind until i
opened your book
changed my life and i tried to convince
my husband at first and honestly he
wasn't ready to receive and um but then
he did change when he watched one of
your videos oh yeah was it certainly
what did you watch alfred so uh one day
she just said i just want you to watch
10 minutes of this and it was your um it
was like a um
you had a financial peace university uh
seven baby steps
and what changed was like the way the
numbers were just adding up and i was
just like wait and i just turned to i
said wait this doesn't make
sense it did
it she was like it does it really does
it did i
did so we ended up watching the whole
thing and then after that i like you
said dave i went gazelle mode we went
gazelle mode and then they got us to
this point now wow that's incredible so
it sounds like the the video was part of
it but you know aisha did a great job
convincing you that this would work
and you know what she did she didn't let
go she stayed on top of me about it and
i think that was the blessing in it that
she stayed on top of me she didn't give
up on me never persistence that's very
cool good for you guys so what does that
mean
what does gazelle intense look like for
you guys what were the sacrifices along
the way where you really went all in on
this thing
seven working seven jobs together we
worked every job that we worked we
worked them together uh my husband he
started his own business we worked that
together yeah so the auto detailing
yeah it's auto details so aisha you're
out there you're out there doing the
cars i'm out there doing the car aisha
yes and i was with him yes i was dave
yes i was i got a picture of you right
here i see you detailing
that's right that or you're praying
beside that car i can't tell which it is
but yeah
we did everything dave we did that we
did door dash we did it in the car
you name it gazelle intensity we got it
done and we made a lot of sacrifices and
a lot of the same meals every single
week and we know about we know about
rice and beans we know about spaghetti
every week we do what we have to do so
we made a lot of sacrifices and our kids
they were phenomenal in this journey
with us they truly were our daughters
nine and and four years old at this time
and they have been phenomenal in our
journey and they're all okay they're not
scarred
no they're not they have learned and our
daughter actually just gave us a goal
for us to she said our next goal because
we just finished our emergency fund it's
a 100 000 and we had to take a deep
breath when she said we said you got it
we're going to make that happen i like
this kid
that's the biggest number she knows
she's a hundred thousand let's do this
that's incredible
what i love about this i don't know that
i've heard this before they were so on
the same page and such a team they even
did the side jobs together all of them
that's that's cool yes that's very cool
pandemic yeah during a pandemic pandemic
and my husband switched careers and i
wasn't happy with my job and you know
what i didn't complain about instead you
said what what can we do and with god
anything is possible and everything is
possible and that's first and foremost
if you would like to be on this journey
you have to make sure you're doing it
the right way and that's how it'll last
forever amen
amen well done
well you guys are the kind of people
that you happen two things instead of
things happening to you
yes
and once you once you get on that side
of things
where you say um
you grab destiny by the throat and say
you're mine i own you
instead of going oh i don't think i
think i'm stuck
you know you ain't never been stuck in
your life either one of you
you just needed you just needed somebody
you just need a plan and we just showed
you made you believe that that thing
would work and yeah you exactly applied
what you were already doing to that
yes he's need a little discipline that's
it that's discipline and that's right
and it was the plan you're right because
we have been taught some certain things
about money or our parents have taught
us certain things about bunny but having
a direction and not being directionless
and being able to follow step by step
this is what you do and then this is
what you do and then if you have that
patience patience attains everything it
strives for so you're going to get that
if you stay on those baby steps and of
course we became impatient at times but
if you stay on the steps you don't get
lost yeah yeah you know you know where
we're going we know what was it worth it
wow
our marriage just like you said we're a
team now but we didn't get here
because of where we were before we had
to let go of a lot of things in order to
gain everything and we're only getting
started so
um
it's given us everything peace has given
us peace it's giving us peace it's
giving us financial peace it's not a
joke people it's easy financial peace i
love it
well i'm so proud of you guys you're an
amazing couple you're a lot of fun to
talk to yeah you have inspired a lot of
people listening and watching this right
now that it's it's doable and you can
knock it out and it's just it's it's
spaghettios and beans and rice baby
bring it
[Music]
i don't i don't even have debt and i
want to get out of some that's how on
fire i am after talking with y'all
that's awesome that's true because it is
a fun journey it is what do you what do
you tell people the key is i mean we
heard a lot of them in the conversation
already but what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is i would
say god first and foremost secondly i
would say discipline
and then um
humbling yourself yeah
a lot of these things that you think you
need you know just humble yourself
and know live below your means so that
you can live be comfortable for the next
30 years and your grandkids can live
even better than you and your great
grandkids and your great great grandkids
because it's not just about us we're
doing this so that we can continue this
foundation to break these generational
curses and to build generational wealth
so that's our why and we're going to
continue to do that there it is a godly
man leaves an inheritance to his
children's children you're amazing you
guys are on fire man you're so fun i am
so i'm so
i'm so pumped where you're gonna be you
guys
you just don't do anything halfway i
mean you go wide open i love it that's
just turned me loose and you that's all
we did you know well thank you you have
been an inspiration to us
y'all are inspirational everybody well
done we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth how you can
too that is definitely the next chapter
in your story i have a prediction beyond
your uh your child's prediction i'm
going with a million not a hundred
thousand i think that's what's coming
here so you're gonna be there before you
know it and also send you a copy of the
total money makeover to uh disrupt
someone in your family or disrupt a
friend that's looking at you they're
giving you the side eye right now and
you're gonna go oh no this is what i did
right here it's what i did right here
you just just read this and then shut up
okay
yeah
all right alfred and aisha from west
hampton west hampton new jersey 34 000
paid off in two years making one to 135
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how you do the phone dead free
screen right there that's the way you
bring it you bring it bring it all on
hey they don't do it halfway man
her phone carrier is gonna charge her
more for that
data overload
i love it that's that's as good as it
gets though get me i need friends like
them they're awesome hey you know you do
become who you hang around with can you
imagine having dinner with them and then
not going and getting out of debt you
can't happen no it can't happen you
become who you hang around with be
careful choose carefully or you can hang
out with someone who or is their spirit
animal oh well you can't get ahead in
america today
try telling that to those two that's a
good impression
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the fine print on ramsey networks
don't miss that podcast season one is
available for listening now brian is in
panama city hey brian what's up hey how
are you today thanks for taking my call
sure how can we help uh um my wife and i
are in the process of selling our
primary residence and after that sale we
will profit approximately 470 000 and my
question is very cool
yeah
my question is is what
uh money should we budget for plus the
additional cash we have to purchase a
new house
how much cash do you have
we have about another 180 000 in cash
okay
and so
you know so you got like 655 000 bucks
right or 750 correct yes and our goal is
to truly be debt free and so you're
going to buy a 655 000 house
if that's
if that's
that would leave us with no reserves no
nothing besides uh retirement accounts
okay well you wouldn't you wouldn't do
that you'd have an emergency fund right
right out of that then and so that's
every dime of cash you have then
that is everything yes yes and so if we
set aside uh 30 then you'd have
uh
625 000 right
right and i guess my question was is
because obviously if we therefore not
carrying a mortgage
that emergency fund we can
fund a lot quicker so i didn't know no i
wouldn't fund it quicker i just it could
be smaller
okay because you don't have to carry
cover a mortgage but i'm not gonna have
you spend your emergency fund on a house
now so you're talking about paying cash
you're not talking about putting the 625
000 as a down payment and then paying
off a mortgage quickly
that is correct we've always
my wife and i we've always had never
lived truly debt-free we've always had a
mortgage and with the sale of this house
um you want to do this is an opportunity
yeah yeah so
what did the house sell for
total it's
920 000. so you talk about moving down
correct
and everybody's okay with that
everybody's okay with that how old are
you guys
42. cool
have you found a house that you like
that's in that price point about 6.25
yes yes yeah we think we we can be in
that price range and what do you make of
yours
well i stay at home um and my wife makes
about 150. so if i went back to work now
that um
if i currently it's 150 if i went back
to work it'd be 300.
okay
i like it i'd buy a six and a quarter
and if you don't like it
if you kind of have a little bit of
regret from doing that and you want to
move up to a million i think you can do
that with cash in a matter of a couple
of couple of three four years if both of
you pour the coals back on right
yes with no house payments you can save
like crazy people and both of you
working again
if you wanted to you could move up on up
in house really easy
my point is that 625 might not be for 30
years it might be for three years
yeah that's that's i guess that's a
great way to look at it and to this
point i haven't looked at it this way
you know it gives you it gives you a
little freedom like you're not trapped
yes if you don't look at it as it
doesn't have to be
permanent now i don't like moving every
three years i don't like moving at all
i've moved about every 13 to 15 years in
my adult life
uh i was in the real estate my mom and
dad were in the real estate business
growing up our furniture was trained to
jump on the truck
so it's ready to go but like
you know there you go and uh
we had one couch that could really
really leap and um but the um
but yeah the the
the idea like you guys bought the house
the townhouse that you bought and you
just paid it off and you all are 100
debt free mortgage and everything but
you didn't buy that going we're going to
stay here 10 years no we knew this was a
it was it was we're going to get in and
get it paid off house exactly and we've
got our dream you know not forever home
obviously because that's not a thing but
we've got our sights set on what's next
and we'd love to pay cash for that and
with brian shovel 300 grand if he gets
back to work and they have no payments
including a mortgage payment you should
be able to do you should be able to move
quickly with brian shovel yeah let's go
if he's going to send it to you
i'd love that
but when you can put you know 200 grand
away a year yeah even after tax i mean
you've got no expenses at this point
except food you know keeping the lights
on all that stuff that's fantastic you
could save up by a million dollar home
in a few years yeah it's it's
and that 650 will have gone up i
appreciate it
so you're in a great spot i love the
heart though of they want to pay cash
they want to do this
we're never mad about exactly what i
would tell you to do but i'm just
questioning because i'm making sure
you know we don't get halfway into this
plan and somebody throws a grenade on it
you don't regret involved exactly
daniel's in birmingham hey daniel
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how's it going good man what's up
um i am self-employed i'm an hvsd
contractor in alabama i've been doing
hvac for about seven years now and i got
life
licensed last year
my question for you is
i have an opportunity to become a w-2
employee again but i'm really
entrepreneurial i like working for
myself
problem is because i just started a new
business it's very volatile
and i made a lot lower i mean we pretty
much just scraped by last year
i've met some clients i've met some
people who have a lot of investment
property and they'd like for me to do
their hvac and so
you know i'd like to say yeah i'll make
great money this year but we don't know
what the future holds for this year
until it happens
and with me and my wife trying to go
like we're finishing up baby step one
right now and trying to finish that up
i'm like should i become a w-2 employee
while i'm
in the sick of paying off debt so not
stable or no no
what do you think you're going to make
this year really
uh really i think i can make 80 this
year and what's the w-2 offer
um
72
okay so
you'd have to be wrong by
50
to
really have made a stupid but decision
yeah okay
so here's what i want you to think about
um and you can make your own decision i
i answered it like if i was in your
shoes okay
right i'd keep going and um
okay there's a couple of things i want
you to walk away from this conversation
with one is you're good at heating air
and you're not yet good at running a
business
right there are two different skills
part one element of running a business
is marketing and getting new clients and
if you have a steady stream of new
clients coming in you can keep their
heat and air fixed because you know how
to do that yeah and you'll probably
figure out a way to catch their checks
okay so uh you'll figure it out if you
can get a steady stream of marketing
going in so you've got to
as a part of your commitment to stay
self-employed
learn how to run a business this coming
year
and that includes marketing
getting new clients you're going to have
to allocate time every day to getting
new clients
that's good yeah and reading about
learning about talking to heat and air
people and how they get new clients
if they're not if they're in a different
city and they're not a competitor of
yours and share their secrets with you
making sure to ask every single client
hey i'm a i'm a one-stop shop it's just
me i need your help please tell your
friends about me it would mean a lot and
then the person that sends you five new
clients makes sure they get a free steak
dinner
that's really good that's a good
marketing strategy this kind of stuff
i'm encouraged to hear this because yeah
i know that you are about security and
securing the home and
that's the second thing i was going to
tell you is security when you work for
someone else is an illusion
yeah because they have to make payroll
they have to run the business and they
have to go into an insecure
marketplace and bring in money so that
you get a check and you have the
illusion of security
there is no security you're only secure
is your ability to leave the cave kill
something and drag it home that's your
only security
yeah and we know we know you can go
we know if if the whole world falls
apart and you're the dumbest guy on the
planet by the end of this time next year
you can go take a job
as a w-2 make an 80. you can get a job
making 80s w-2 and so so i want you to
work on marketing a certain number of
hours a week i want you to work on
learning to run a business this year and
i want you to understand your security
comes from you and from god not from
working for somebody who is insecure
who's supposed to pay you money
and that's how payroll actually works in
the real world boys and girls
there's very few places you work that is
that are actually secure
uh that's just an illusion so hold on
we're gonna send you a copy of the book
entre leadership and uh if i were you
i'd keep running my business i think
you're the dog yep absolutely that's the
way to do it man good luck
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsay call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print our
fabulous expose podcast where he exposes
where the
fine print is screwing you because it is
and it's the old saying about fine print
and we've got 10 episodes in the uh in
the can from last season you can listen
to now and
planning out um
how many of these episodes are going to
be about time shares going forward oh my
goodness we need to do an entire season
dedicated to that
my brain would melt
but we did have a lot of fun and one of
the biggest ones we've we've heard uh
feedback on is the true cost of credit
card rewards because it's one of those
things you can send to your buddy who
has his feelings about rewards and you
go just listen please just listen to
this
it's it's the chuck e cheese skee-ball
tickets that's what it is that's the
fabulous metaphor you put it and we
haven't even dove into nfts yet oh my
goodness oh i can't wait one deloney and
i were talking yesterday
the meta universe is now there and
walmart has announced they're going into
the space so you can buy virtual drapes
for your virtual house from walmart
that is if you would buy your drapes at
walmart maybe you should get them at
target i don't know or coals i don't
know where should you get them
kmart's not open anymore is it no they
shut down i think yeah they're virtually
there's one left over and they're
virtually there they're virtually there
yeah the metaverse stuff hurts my brain
as well there's a there's a lot of
strange stuff happening i just saw an
article uh real estate in the virtual
universe is 500 up someone spent 450
grand to buy the the house next to snoop
dogg in the virtual universe
uh we talked about it yesterday the
little kids this is the generation that
grew up playing animal farm and you
could buy stuff and have a virtual pig
and it was like not real bacon
farmville i knew james would know
farmville that's it and james see james
knows this he's obsessed james did you
ever buy a virtual pitch i never played
farmville or bought any virtual picks
but we looked it up yesterday okay you
went and looked it up after that
deloney and i butchered the name of it
yeah that's i knew it was there though
and um you could actually buy things for
your farm little kids could spend five
bucks and stuff and spend money and now
they've grown up and now they bought
a pretend house next door to snoop dogg
snoop dogg's pretend house that is a
real house
i'm so confused exactly
wow he has a real house
but
there's a pretend house in the in the
virtual metaverse in the pretend world
and you can buy the pretend house next
to his pretend house in the pretend
world
that's what we need to start calling
instead of virtual pretend virtual means
kinda
we're you know like if i say i virtually
love my wife she would say that means
you don't
listening i'd be okay with that i there
i do virtually love my dog at times yes
and he's aware of that so the way he
acts he virtually loves you yeah well no
he no he he unconditionally loves me
because he's a dog not a cat but yeah
but the uh uh but
oh that's good
but you know hey this uh the whole idea
that
even the word virtual has got it means
sorta kinda yeah it means not really not
quite it's
virtual now almost
i i virtually got an a but it was a b
virtual reality means not reality i was
virtually magnesium
i virtually graduated magna [ __ ] laude
and said it was thank you lottie
well we're having a good day there are
people that virtually graduated now
that's right they just because of covert
they quit
you can do a lot of stuff virtual if
it's not real it's not real
that's so strange
well nothing's real it's all the mate
it's the matrix
we'll help you guys in real life if you
want to give us a call how's that
and you can check out the podcast
fine print which is what started this
little rant here other than the fact
we've got these things stored in our
brain and they just had to come out our
mouths but um yeah check out the fine
print there's ten episodes there um
one on credit card points one on fico
score that's very informative that's
right
one on uh
student loans student loans bankruptcy
bitcoin the bankruptcy one was really
good thank you
the bitcoin one was excellent
it was excellent thank you you really
because you know that what we find is is
that a lot of people the vast majority
of people investing in bitcoin don't
even know what it is they just bought it
because their broke brother-in-law
thought it was an awesome idea and they
thought they had fomo they had to get in
on it
uh virtually
and so um
i'm just going to drop that word in my
sentences occasionally you'll be really
hip just to be uh just every keep
everything moving right along stay
trending dave you just keep calling
everything virtual if i'm just um yeah
i'm a virtual host
i'm virtually a billionaire so there you
go
in the in the metaverse i can we can all
be what we want yeah because you could
just sell a lot of stuff that in there
and
yeah make a lot of money that isn't
there fake money this is where it all
breaks down i'm so confused let's stick
to something we know about
probably all right julie's in seattle
hey julie welcome to the ramsay show
thank you thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
well i am 66 my husband is 62
i'm pretty much retired he still works
and we make about 60 000 a year
our house is paid for and worth about
eight hundred thousand
our trailer and cars are paid for we
have thirty thousand in an emergency
fund
and seven hundred or six hundred and
eleven
thousand dollars in retirement we have
long-term insurance
and we're not contributing right now to
our retirement you're millionaires
awesome way to go
thank you
thanks to you and following your plan
for years
um
i want to know if i can take some we can
take some money out of retirement yeah
we can yes
how much are you going to take out of
your 600 000 worth of retirement to fix
up your house your 800 000 house 440
yes
you had to call me about 40 000 when you
have when you have almost 2 million
[Laughter]
yes i'm very frugal and very cheap and
i'm just afraid if something happens to
my husband and i'm on my own
is this house falling apart what what
kind of state is it forty thousand
dollars she's not even fixing up the
kitchen good
yeah
what are you doing with the 40.
what are you doing well i've got the new
appliances in the kitchen but i don't
have the cabinets and the walls painted
or the cabinets done and the counter
um so just kind of lipstick in there i
don't need to be real fancy the deck
definitely needs to be done it's a
million dollar house you need to do this
right don't cheap out
two million dollar house no i said it is
a i said it is a million dollar house
almost
don't cheap out on the kitchen and
devalue the house
okay captain captain frugal julie julie
you live like no one else and now if you
remember how the saying goes you can now
live like no one else so we gotta
remember the second half too
listen you didn't call me up one to
spend 400 i might have said
i might have get ted you take a chill
pill but 40 grand honey listen if you
take 40 000 and burn it in the middle of
the kitchen table it doesn't change your
life one minute
oh i'm so happy you did it you did it
you made it you made it you did it you
lived like no one else now fix your
freaking kitchen
i love it this is awesome love making
people happy that's what we do
it's not even a virtual kitchen it's a
real kitchen and she's fixing it with
real money get the virtual address she
really saved
wow
real people
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
well it's time to put 2021 behind us
last year left a lot of people feeling
burned out sluggish
or as your spirit animal we're stuck
we're stuck we're stuck
but 2022 is your fresh start this is
your wake-up call you're ready to own
this year well we are running our new
year's sale right now so you can get 73
off our best-selling books assessments
and envelope systems and that includes
the brand new book baby steps
millionaires that will show you the
quickest right way to become a
millionaire
it's on sale there as well not for sale
at ten dollars but there's a lot of
books here at ten dollars be sure and
check them out
if you're having a hard time bouncing
back from the wild year check them all
out redefining anxiety by dr john
deloney is there for 10 bucks total
money makeovers there for 10 bucks the
essential cash envelope system is there
for 10 bucks and all of our best-selling
books are there as well check them all
out ramseysolutions.com
backslash store
xavier is with us in huntington west
virginia hi xavier how are you
doing well sir thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
well i am in baby step two and i have
some very well meeting friends i was
actually in their wedding when they got
married and uh their their kids called
me young so i'm really close uh to that
family
and so when i found out that i was
becoming debt-free
they were really hesitant i have made
some stupid mistakes before so they're
they're really concerned that it may not
be the the best thing so how could i
explain to them in a logical way
that being debt-free is possible it's
wise and you can still have nice things
even though you may not have
what you could get with a loan or
something like that
xavier do your friends pay your bills
no they do not then their opinion and
your personal finances
don't matter and i that hurts to hear
but the truth is the best way you can
convince them is by doing it
and you go yeah i became debt-free 18
months later and here i am i get to live
the life i want i'm not held back by
debt and they go hold on
how'd you do that because right now it's
a theory to them right
right and it's a theory coming from a
guy with a bad track record on theories
you
right
not me right right exactly exactly
hey uh listen here's the thing
one of the ways that one of the things
we find when we study millionaires is
they will often tell us when we're
having conversations with them that
their breakthrough came
when they
loved their friends and their family but
they no longer gave them a vote
and i think i am right there yeah you
know i i think your friend loves you
i just think he's stupid about money
and i don't think you're gonna convince
him from the seat that you're sitting in
because you're not sitting in a seat of
credibility so george is right you go
get out of debt and you pile up some
money and you can tell him nothing about
what he needs to do but always just tell
him your story and go listen i paid off
everything and i don't have any payments
you know how that feels it's awesome i
feel so awesome on any payments and now
that i don't have any payments you know
what i've got i got money and i got
money to do this and i got money to do
that because i'm not paying it all out
in payments and it's just awesome and
all you could all you can do is talk
about you
and then they'll go yeah but what about
me well i don't know i can show you how
to do it i guess but i'm not going to
tell you how to do it because you you
know i'm not that guy that was you
you're that guy
yeah i appreciate that thank you yeah so
i think that's what you do you just got
to go on and do it anyway um
and
you know and and hopefully they will you
know it'll be kind of a
it doesn't have to be snarky but it can
kind of be a toby keith moment like how
do you like me now you know
and um
you just kind of play that song in the
background and yeah
and you always say if if people are
think your financial plan is stupid
you're on the right track broke people
think your financial plan is off track
then you're right on track yeah that's
how you know you're winning that is and
and
you know george the number of times i i
mean i went to high school i grew up my
high school graduating class was 425
people
and um
i mean i'm old enough a few of them have
passed away now right but uh
but but um the
there's a
bunch of those folks i considered very
good friends
and i've kept up at moderate degrees
with several of them through the years
but the number of them that are in my
life once every six months today
um
two
you know and my in other words my
friends group has changed from my high
school well that's everybody right i'm
not different from anybody else that's
everyone if you're 60 years old and
you're still running around with your
old high school buddies that's a little
strange really it is it's unusual um it
doesn't mean that you're a snob it
doesn't mean that they're snobs it
doesn't mean any of that it just means
people change people grow they move they
do different things and so this may be
one of the cases with xavier it may be
that this is the thing he was in their
wedding and i mean i guess i was in
their wedding and i don't even know
where they are now you know and if
you've got emotional maturity i mean
i've got plenty of friends who disagree
with me financially we just don't talk
about finances there's a lot of other
things you can talk about we can still
be friends if we can't have a
disagreement and still be friends then
we aren't really friends exactly
um that's the other thing that goes with
it that's a good point i like that
lauren is with us in charlotte north
carolina hey lauren welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave and george how you guys doing
better than we deserve how can we help
great so my husband and i have been
working on baby step two but we want to
get through it faster and in a smart way
we have baby number two on the way
and
yeah thank you
and expected daycare cost is kind of
what's prompted our question here so we
still have sixty five thousand 000 in
student loans to tackle and we picked up
extra jobs to do this
we don't have a whole lot of
monetary value to our uh
what we own
to sell aside from my husband's truck
which happens to be paid off uh-oh uh
both of our vehicles are completely paid
off what are your vehicles worth
kelly
kelly blue book value on his truck
is about 18 to 19 000. um
do we sell
sell the truck what about your car
my car is a 99 jeep it was a gift from a
family member
a blue book on it
uh on my car it's probably not more than
three thousand dollars okay all right so
that's a total of your vehicles what's
your household income
a hundred and ten thousand together
without the side job and you have sixty
five thousand dollars left in
debt and what are your side jobs
bringing in
um probably only about two to three
hundred a week
they suck
yeah i mean our our jobs take up a lot
of time so our side jobs don't really
give us
well you're done you got it you're not
got a good side job
no i mean these are all you know kind of
kind of working five hours here and five
hours there
yeah our permanent jobs take up quite a
bit of time
um
we do have uh aside from our emergency
fund we do have 15 000
so we could take our student loans down
to 50 which is the plan um
but you know we want to get through this
faster we want to be
doing the debt free screen except for
the part where you didn't use your 15
000.
well we just did that we did that fairly
quickly in like the last you saved that
15 quickly
yeah we did we've
we have been issuing it for too long and
so about five six months ago we decided
we're jumping in we are still issuing it
do you not know what the baby steps are
no we do hopefully
what part of the baby steps has 15 000
in savings while you have 65 000 student
loans none of the baby steps have that
yeah well i mean i guess we're just
trying to figure out you know
your own plan so you got 15 to your name
right now in cash yes
yes so let's take that from
let's take that down to one so that
gives you 14 to put on the debt which
puts you at what 51 there correct i
wouldn't sell the car personally i
wouldn't either i'd keep your truck
you're not going to create any uh cash
flow you don't have a payment on it and
it's not worth 45 grand so it's not
you're gonna have to turn around and buy
a 12 grand car anyways so you guys need
to hustle get better side jobs focus
hunker down and you can get rid of this
thing in six to eight months
uh
pushing it
even we get rid of it in the year
you get rid of it here you go the other
part of your issue is you're still going
out to eat you're still doing a bunch of
other crap you may not even be doing
your budget
so you're still just kind of playing
around the fringes of this stuff hold on
i'm going to send you
a copy of the book the total money
makeover and i want you to follow it
exactly
it works your plan sucks
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show where we talk about your
relationships your money your work and
your life george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today bruce is
with us in fort myers florida hi bruce
what's up
hey dave hey george i appreciate what
you guys do god bless you guys both for
uh spreading the good news and uh
helping people out with their finances
uh my question today is uh
what are your thoughts dave or both your
gentleman's thoughts on taking a degree
for a resume to get a job in corporate
america because the context here is i've
been in the military five years um now
i'm in the reserve
and have a couple buddies who've done so
and um it's not illegal but it's looked
at as unethical but there's a lot of
jobs out there that require degrees and
there's like a thirty thousand dollar
separation from you know certain jobs
that require them and don't require them
but um so what's unethical here
just the integrity of
pretty much lying on your resume i
suppose but the company does doesn't
even verify that you have a degree or
anything they just want to see it oh i
thought you said you were going to
really get a degree instead of just
saying you have one
well that's my plan but i wanted your
two cents on it because it's
it's uh not just the money thing of
course but like i mean there's a lot of
career opportunities and i know a lot of
cfos at these companies who don't have
degrees and they've made it by word of
mouth by relationships by
everything but a degree and it's like
is it worth it or
uh i mean i mean not is it worth it but
it doesn't make sense to if you're
asking us if you should lie on your
resume the answer is no
uh if the answer if you're wanting to
know should you get a degree and
actually get one so that you can get a
job that pays 30 grand more that is a
discussion we can have but no i'm not
going to tell you to go lie about having
a bachelor's degree so you can go get a
job
even if it works i don't feel good about
that
right and that's the thing a lot i have
a couple friends who've done it and i
don't get better friends i don't care
about your crooked friends um you need
to be a man of integrity
right and that's i mean that's what i
assumed was it was let me tell you what
let me tell you i i don't hire people
here we've got 1157 people working on
our team today
that's as of this morning
and um i don't hire people based on
having a degree
not a single person in here got hired
because they had a degree
they got hired because at some point in
the interviewing process we
became convinced that they could do the
job we were hiring them for now some of
that being convinced might be
that they have a degree but we have
executive directors of marketing who do
not have marketing degrees and we have
some that have a master's in marketing
both and both can do the job and they
both got the job because they can do the
job if however i was to discover with
any one of the team members that worked
here no matter how long they worked here
that they had lied about having a degree
to get the job i would fire them
instantaneously
not because of the degree but because
they're a liar and i don't want to work
with liars
right
that's fair and i i i i'm on your side
dave i just had to check in because i
know people have done it and again i
know you're not saying i know people
have done it too i had a lady that
worked here one time that told us she
had a master's degree and after she quit
she came back five years later she's a
friend and said i have felt guilty since
i've known you because i lied to you the
entire time i've known you and i have to
come clean and tell you i do not have a
degree a master's degree in marketing
and she worked here i don't know 25
years ago or something and i still know
her to this day and i still like her but
i would have fired her for lying yeah on
that so bruce what's the harm in you
just going to get a degree if that's
what you want to do do you have to have
a degree to succeed in corporate america
no do you is a degree valuable some are
can you get in the door some places
without a degree yes
can you get into
getting it
uh do the door some places without a
degree no some places require a degree
for you to even have a conversation and
that isn't a place i want to work anyway
because they're more concerned about
pedigrees and degrees than they are
actually getting the frequent freaking
work done
right and to answer your question george
the context is kind of like i've been
the special forces for the marine corps
and i know some guys in the field teams
and like etc and so like that experience
is
way more than you can get any college
degree i agree the compare it's just
different and it's a different kind of
experience and expertise so like but
dude if you ran if you ran a seal team
you can project manage
right but
i guess my question is like it's there
like a lot of things in america are
backwards of course that's well known
but
requiring a degree seems just like a
such a bad filter to have here it's just
not it's not if the if the 100 filter is
you must have a degree
between you and me i wouldn't want to
work there
you got it okay
do you know what you want to do
it would be sales some type of business
development but sales related
very few sales positions require a
degree
they require the ability to sell
the ability to make the ability to
handle your verbal skills and articulate
an idea craft a narrative create a
persuasive environment and show people
the need and fill the need this is sales
build value that is greater than the
amount of time and the amount of money
that the customer is going to put forth
and the customer will part with their
money every single time and that's sales
that's how it works he's got a free
degree from dave do you have a degree i
do in communication no one's ever asked
no one cares
but
but you started here as a lowly intern
that's right with it works your way all
the way up to the email bag that's right
i was in marketing though for four years
and my degree helped i don't think it
was a factor in the conversation it was
a factor in that some of the things you
learned in getting the degree or you put
tools in your belt exactly and i've got
a business degree i don't have a
master's degree i do have a phd in d-umb
yep which is one less than john deloney
has
so there's something to be said
you're at least half as smart as john
no matter what your phd is in
sorry dude i got to tell you if you
depending on what your job was in the
seal teams um
i worked a lot with those guys a lot
with special forces guys and um
we we do a lot of stuff with the
military and i'm a tactical shooter i
enjoy hanging out with them and learning
from them on that stuff and so
you're more than qualified to step into
some of these roles if you can just get
the interview so hang on we're going to
send you ken coleman's two books
proximity principle and from paycheck to
purpose read those and you'll land the
job you do not have to have a degree to
go into sales
not when you've got military experience
with special forces you don't
and um
and you certainly want to continue to be
a man of honor and a man of integrity
because that's how you started your life
and you need to continue your life that
way that is how
um most people prosper is from integrity
very few people with a lack of integrity
have a long-term
prosperity and that was part of the
millionaire study that we did as well
because there's integrity shows up all
the time yeah
and so i got to tell you that's why i i
there's
there's very few things on the planet i
hate
as much as taxes
i
hate
taxes i think they're unfair
i think the money is completely wasted
by washington i think it's a disaster
i'm politically philosophically
spiritually opposed to the unbelievable
level of taxation that our country puts
on us while still 50 percent of
americans pay zero in federal income tax
and they take my freaking head off with
taxes
but i pay every
dime
i owe exactly not a penny more
but we calculate it precisely
because it has nothing to do with the
irs it has nothing to do with the stupid
congress it has nothing to do with the
stupid federal government it has to do
with my
integrity
and so
we run a lot of cash through this place
and every freaking dime of it is
reported
exactly
and you know so i get audited it'll be
no problem
no problem come on in they just don't i
don't cheat on my taxes and if i was
ever going to cheat on anything
by god it'd be that's the place to do it
it would be i would start right there if
i'm going to be a cheater that'd be the
first line on the list right there buddy
you wouldn't add a degree on your resume
dave
that one don't even come up oh because
i'm not pissed about that yeah i guess
you haven't had to do a job interview in
like ever
it's been a while yeah
yeah i'd love to see that though our hr
department interviewing you for the job
a ceo be like that would be bad
i don't think i could get a job here
it's tough you'd get worn out just in an
interview process the interview process
i don't think i can make it but
it wouldn't be because of lack of
integrity though that's true this is the
ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us america
we're glad you're here open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five mark is in salt lake city hey mark
what's up
hi i'm doing good um
i just have some issues with some family
and money okay
uh my parents had given me 200k for a
house
that we ended up buying because they're
ailing in age
and they couldn't maintain the property
they had and my other siblings weren't
really helping
and so it was easier for them to move
closer and be with us
so i was perfectly fine and i said look
so you took a 200 000 gift from them and
then you bought a house so you could
take care of them
in so many words yes i already had my
home already paid off everything
basically that home wouldn't work for
them so i had to purchase the newer home
to
make it more accessible for them for
their age and then their requirements
like their vehicles and other things of
that nature
how old are your parents
in their 80s
okay
okay sounds like you've done a very nice
thing and they
helped
provide for you to take care of them so
where did it blow up
speak directly into your phone mark
sorry we're having a hard time hearing
you they were uh being racist and sexist
and i gave him basically three chances
to stop because i have two kids at home
so essentially since they couldn't abide
by that i said that's fine you can have
the top half i'll have the bottom half
and
you know if you ever need anything let
me know
so essentially
i overheard
my wife uh well she told me she
overheard them because they're hard of
hearing um they were saying that they
were afraid that um that was gonna
murder them and take their money
but they were gonna ask for their 200k
back
[Music]
okay so women they were being racist and
sexist
and they're 80 years old
well it's not the fact that they needed
to change
i didn't ask that i just said look if
like you know you're coming upstairs and
you know a racist section you have to
talk into your phone you're mumbling
yeah i said if you're going to say
sexist and raises things as a tv i you
know you got to be cognizant there's two
little children running around they're
going to hear that you got to stop
politely and so you know that was kind
of taken care of
how old are you
i am 30
uh almost 40 years old
okay so what are you going to do
well i don't know you know i mean
so the 200k um you know it was
essentially given and i didn't want it i
said no thank you i'll take care of it
myself and then it became an ultimatum
where they said we we give it to you and
we're not going to do it number one and
then number two it helps us give us a in
the house which was fine i was like you
know you're welcome to put up and do
whatever you want on your floor you're
you know i can't have it downstairs
because i have two little ones and i
have to make sure they're safe
so if something's unsafe you know i just
can't have it but when did all this blow
up
so it's just it's been a progression
over years and then finally
when did this whole thing blow up and
they move upstairs and decide you were
going to kill them for their money no no
no so the thing is is um
they've been upstairs the whole time no
i mean you ran them upstairs and told
them to go away because they were
yelling racist stuff at the television
no no no no that was the the upstairs is
more um you know it has the master
bedroom it has a bathroom you told me
that you told them to go upstairs if
they couldn't behave
well no see they automatically live
upstairs and we would come up for dinner
and things of that nature oh so they
have to stay up there okay then you're
running no no no so they they have
they're more than welcome to come down
but again they're elderly so coming down
the stairs isn't really an option you're
missing the point i'm asking when this
big conversation where you all had got
crossways happen a week ago a day ago a
month ago
again i gave him three chances and what
was the third strike dude finally
you're talking circles what was the
third strike
so the third strike was when i was um
essentially i missed uh we tried to have
dinner on sundays
together
and so
i was running late there was an accident
on the freeway i called them told them i
wasn't going to make it
and then on the way home i got a phone
call from my kids boys saying hey we
changed the meeting happens tonight can
you make it and i said i'll give it a
shot so i get home
i have just enough time to drop off the
kids two days ago look
this is uh
three months ago okay i said look okay
so you've been living in this tent just
stop i don't hear all that you've been
living in this tension for three months
yeah and well in a way because
essentially you need to sell the house
and they need to go on their way
and you need to give them 200k
and then you go back to your other
property or something like your other
property the equivalent thereof and they
need to have their own life
well i understand and that's the easy
way to say it but again i mean you don't
just get to sell a property buy a house
that you want that's going to work for
you instantly the market here isn't like
that it's not oh here you go you know
this is
you know what you're going to get and
walk away so essentially they pawned the
200k off on me and i said i don't want
it yeah but you have crazy people in the
upstairs of your house
well they turned around and said look
here's your inheritance
your two other brothers i heard all that
you have crazy people in the upstairs of
your house who are yelling racial
epitaphs at the television and they're
telling other people that you're going
to kill them
yeah this is not going well have you
noticed that it's irrational i don't
know what to do with the irrational i i
do get rid of it
yeah but i mean then i'm worried how do
i come up with 200k you sell the house
isn't it not in the equity of the house
well so no i i went ahead because we
we're we are very well financially off
okay what's your house worth
we paid about let's just round it to
900k it's worth 900k and what do you owe
on it
nothing
sell the house hand them 200k and go buy
a 700 000 house
it's really not rocket science mark well
i understand but
okay it sounds like it's hard for you
emotionally but the actual step is is
easy we're telling you sell the house
that's it you're saying it can't be done
well the thing is again i mean you want
me to get your 80 year old crazy parents
to behave like they're supposed to
behave and i can't help you with that
you know i'm well that's not what i'm
asking my question is is really
ethically do they deserve the 200k yes
they're the ones who gave it to me i
know but you don't need the money you
just told us you're so financially well
off you don't need the money
i agree this is not about the money
yeah you could keep the money if you
want but i gotta you gotta give give
them the money so they can go buy a
nursing home or go find a place live
with your brother or something he has
plenty go drive somebody else crazy
okay i'd be done with this i'd give him
200k you're gonna have to say you tried
to set some boundaries inside your own
home and it didn't work because people
who don't like boundaries generally it's
shocking they don't like boundaries and
so that's what happened they went
bananas when you drew a line in the sand
okay there's no scenario where they stay
there and it all just works out
well i don't think they should you know
i agree with you 100 but you want to
kick them out and keep the 200k that's
not going to work either
no because i'm not they're deciding to
leave and i'm okay with that you know
what i mean oh are they leaving
well they so i just found out today
that's right
today
okay i help you i mean i'm not here to
hinder you i'm here to right i was here
always here to help right
right well yeah help them get out and
get a place and and do you have 200 000
cash laying around
no i mean i have
like we in our savings have 80. okay
okay and so we have that but you know i
have kids school to pay for
um i mean really that's the only
bill i have but you have a house you
don't need now if they move out
well we do i mean because we still need
the space yes
you don't need the entire house that
holds two people in the upstairs that
aren't there anymore dude
um
and so i
okay what would i do
um i think you're highly emotional and
you're having a real problem thinking
through this clearly so i'll tell you
what i would do i'd sell my house i'd
hand them 200k i wouldn't be in a big
hurry to do it but i'd do it reasonably
and judiciously
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
where we talk about your relationships
your money and your work we're here to
help
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five erica in destin
florida starts off this hour hi erica
how are you
hi sir i'm good how are you better than
i deserve what's up
all right so you have to be gentle with
me because i'm sensitive uncle dave
okay i'll try to be nice what's up
so
me and my husband are currently active
duty military i'm 22 he's 28. thank you
for your service yes thank you yes sir
thank you for the support
so um
i'm my contract is coming to an end as
in
my final out date is may 2nd and my
contract will be over which means we
won't be receiving we'll be losing half
of our income
and we got quite a bit of debt
and i'm nervous
all right so what are you gonna do with
your life honey
i don't know
i don't have
any college or anything like that
i
i don't i don't know
if i have to stay in
to support my family i mean i'll do
whatever i have to do you need to go on
you need to do you can stay in there's
nothing wrong with a career in the
military but it doesn't sound to me like
that that was your choice you just don't
know what you're going to was your
problem
yes is that right
yes sir okay
so if you close your eyes and you said i
could click my heels together i'm
dorothy on the wizard of oz
and the men behind the curtain could
tell you do whatever you wanted to do
what would you go do
anything i wanted to do that's what i
said
well
i would love to be i would love to work
for myself i'd love to grow a blog
and maybe be you know a youtube
influencer that would be like my dream
but i don't know how realistic that is
what do you have anything to say
well yeah i think so
are you gonna be entertaining or are you
gonna be informative
you know a little bit of both i'm pretty
smart okay i guess
and humble yeah
[Laughter]
you're fun
you're fun i like you
thank you now erica in the meantime i
love this idea that you're passionate
about about being a blogger influencer
and let me tell you it is realistic it's
gonna be about 28 times harder than you
think it will be uh this doesn't just
happen it's not a job you apply for it's
a job that you have to put in 50 60
hours a week until it's working and then
you continue to make it work uh but i
absolutely want you to pursue that in
the meantime it sounds like you might
need to get some income in the door and
get rid of this debt which will free you
up to focus more time on that dream of
yours right yes so let that fuel you on
this debt-free journey what how much
debt do you guys have
so in total we got like
49. okay what's your husband mike
my husband makes 50. okay and how many
kiddos in the background do i hear
just one she's just loud
how old is the loud one
five months oh
he's perfect okay what kind of debt is
this
um well my husband has some credit card
debt and personal loans from his prior
marriage and then i have a car
okay how much is the car debt twenty
thousand
of the 49.
yes okay let's sell that
yes okay that's exactly what we already
planned on doing
we just got rid of almost half your debt
so you're down to 29 000 in debt now you
guys feeling a lot better do you have
any savings any cash
a thousand dollars okay working the plan
i love it you work in the play that's
the perfect amount to have so what is
ken's what's ken's assessment called uh
get clear the get clear assessment have
you taken that yet
no okay it's thirty dollars i'm gonna
give it to you for free
it'll take you about 30 minutes to take
it and it'll help you it's in ken
coleman's
process from paycheck to purpose the
first thing you've got to do is you have
to get clear on where it is you want to
go with your career
okay now i think you need to develop a
plan a career
or a plan b career whatever we want to
call it that is what george is saying
where you get out there and quote get a
job right now and you start your youtube
thing as your side hustle and let it
grow
now uh
i got a few million folk on the youtube
and um
uh
tens of millions and um so here let me
give you a little clue about this
because we've studied these
folks uh that are making a lot of money
on youtube and i'm
i just kind of joined it because we were
already doing this and they just put it
on youtube but so it's a little
different than starting from the ground
up but we know a lot of people that are
doing very well in that space and
uh what you need to have as you work on
that but really this is after you take
the get clear and you figure out some
kind of a job you can go get while you
begin to work on the youtube but you got
that part right
yes sir okay now then you start working
with your blog and your youtube and
really the big thing you need to do and
you can do it out of this get clear
assessment as well
is you need to not figure out what it is
you're going to say or whether you're
going to be entertaining or whether
you're going to be smart
or both but instead what it is you're
wanting to accomplish
who it is you're wanting to help
okay if you if you're a comedian what
you want to accomplish is you want to
make people laugh
yes and that's fine that's your job then
okay so my job is so if i'm doing
something on youtube then it needs to
make people laugh that's what i'm doing
so you need to say what is your youtube
show for what is your blog for
and just i want to be an influencer is
not a four
okay who is it you're gonna help and
what help are you providing them
entertainment information
whatever it is and really start to get a
mission
to drive your youtube channel because if
you don't have somewhere you're going
with it it won't go anywhere
okay so i did already started okay
yes do you have any idea what your
mission is i'm curious
yes sir i would love to empower
just young women but especially new moms
i feel like there was a lot i didn't
learn growing up
and i've had to teach myself
yeah a new mom's empowerment blog and
youtube channel i'm in okay that's it
that's exactly what i'm talking about
that's exactly what i'm you're already
ahead of me you already knew what to do
i didn't even help you at all okay so
good yeah i think you start all of that
but in the meantime i think you do get a
job
and it's a little hard to walk off from
a five-month-old
that's part of what you're struggling
with too
uh it's a little tough but you guys need
the income right now
and you need to clear up this debt
you're only 22. you got all kinds of
time here and if you can get that blog
and that youtube channel making some
money you can quit that job but you got
to get it making money first not just be
a dream
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
well you hear me say all the time that
every adult needs a will
that's true
it's a basic adult responsibility to get
your will done there's really not a good
enough excuse to not have one you need a
will
if you have changed states of residence
you need a new will
if you've changed your marital status
you need a new will
you need to keep keep your will updated
based on where you live and what your
marital and family status is
all the time
and you've heard me recommend an online
will as the fastest most cost effective
way to get a simple will taken care of
get a lot of questions asking if that's
right for everyone's situation and what
if you need a trust or you need a mirror
will or what kind of powers of attorney
a lot of those basic things you can get
online
so if you want to learn about all of
this you can take a quick quiz to figure
out the kind of will that you need to
protect your family and your wishes
free service go to ramsey solutions dot
com slash wills quiz
slash wills quiz ramsey solutions dot
com slash will's quiz and it'll walk you
through the whole process and i know i
can think of a lot of things i'd rather
do than take a wills quiz
but you've got to get your will and you
got to make sure it's done right and you
got to take care of your family it's
part of being an adult
so get her done ramsay solutions dot com
slash wills quiz our question today
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings free samples free shipping and
new promos all the time you'll save even
more always use the promo code the magic
word ramsay to get the best possible
deal today's question comes from laura
in tennessee our family has been a dave
ramsey family i always agreed with the
quote expensive college is a ripoff idea
and my older son is in community college
now my younger son announced at age
seven that he wanted to become an
economist and fix poverty and wealth
inequality almost a decade later he
still wants to become an economist he
wants to go to harvard or wharton and
feel strongly that going to such a
school would help him develop
connections that would allow him to
advance his goals as jobs for economists
are mostly appointed we can afford to
pay his way but is it really worth 250
000 in tuition alone
hmm
there's a lot going on here um i'm
intrigued by it i'd personally this is
my personal take i don't think it's
worth 250 000 dollars to go be an
economist for the connections
but if they have the cash to do it and
that's something they want to do for
their son
that's the decision they can make but
personally if i'm if i'm mom and dad i'm
going no we're not doing this
okay
this kid is obviously a child of great
intellect and he's also a super nerd yep
seven years old he wanted two seven
years old i want to be an economist and
do away with wealth inequality
what seven-year-old says that come on
strange ones very smart ones yeah that's
an unusual child
and so uh in a good way maybe but maybe
maybe
um
and it sounds like she's 17. now the
child is she said almost a decade later
so he must be 17 close to college
a decade or so 16 years old okay let me
help you with this at 16 years old you
do not know what you're talking about
you're so full of crap that it's
unbelievable
i want to go to harvard because i can
make connections because economist jobs
are all appointed
horse crap you're 16.
you do not know what you're talking
about
you don't know what you're talking about
young child
this is why you have parents thank god
you need parents you need a keeper even
if you're a very smart and unusually
bright young man who has had a focus
since you're a child a little child
but um so here's the thing there are
economists in all parts of life
um i have a friend who is one of the
best-known economists in the world he
invented the laffer curve art laffer um
he has a phd from economics i believe it
was cambridge if i remember
i served in reagan's cabinet and uh he
served on the in the trump cabinet as
well wrote the last trump tax law is
absolutely brilliant and made almost
none of his money
doing those things
he instead manages
um
wealth
for others i'll just leave it at that
and um like lots of wealth with bees on
the end of it billions
and so um an art's like 80 something
years old now he's brilliant he's again
he's a friend still real shy in the area
probably one of the best-known
economists on the planet that's alive at
this moment in the top five anyway
and so um
he he would tell you that education is
vital and education is important and he
would tell you cambridge was worth the
money because of the path that he ended
up going on
but i will tell you that that job
there's only about three of those
in the world
and the rest of time the economist ends
up working for a mutual fund company
or the economist ends up working for a
financial planning company or the
economist ends up working for
a large
corporate
entity that needs some economic
predictions
and models run out on their uh revenue
projections and an economist and in all
of those cases there's no roi on what
you're talking about
so these schools are not better schools
and no they do not provide better
connections they're just more famous
uh let me also let me point out to you
this here's an example of what i'm
talking about
wall street journal did a study a few
years ago
and 78
of the forbes
i'm sorry 78 of the s p 500 the 500
largest publicly traded companies
on the stock exchange 78 8 out of 10 of
the ceos graduated from state schools
i'll help you with that again
of the largest 500 companies traded on
the stock exchange 8 out of 10 ceos
graduated from
state schools
they went to
the university of fill in the state but
dave they're missing out on the
connections and harvard but they're the
ceo of household name companies
and by the way the cfos same situation
the cos
same situation
the chief digital officers some of them
didn't even graduate from college
and so yes you can get a degree there
but this idea that the connections you
make in college are going to open your
doors and make you successful is as dumb
as the idea that the degree
is going to make you successful what
makes you successful at the end of the
day is you
education is important it's even vital
but where you get it and who you are
connected to there is no data
to back up this theory of where you went
to school matters
that these prestigious universities that
there's an roi on them we cover a bunch
of this in borrowed future i was just
going to say this is all reminding me
very heavily of the bard future
documentary where we go into this and we
talk about is is school worth it are
degrees worth it what about trade
schools and state schools versus the big
name and what we found out was that
there's there's really no correlation
between success
of hey i went to harvard or i went to a
state school
learn to play golf join a country club
for a tenth of what you would pay at
that school and go get a degree from a
state school and you'll be better off
and if this kid it really has the
intellect that i think he has i think he
can get scholarships they're going to be
knocking at the door trying to get they
can go for free that's fine but that
isn't what she asked we can afford to
pay is it really worth 250 000
no it's not worth a quarter of a million
dollars no it's not no no but is he
smart enough that he's gonna be just
fine and maybe he could be an economist
and love what he does sure yeah but i
wouldn't pay a quarter million dollars
for the pleasure of it yeah and uh
it's uh um but don't just because your
kid has
an unusual proclivity for
articulating his ideas at seven years
old
does not mean he actually knows what
he's talking about
to get poor 17
and sometimes parents get all enamored
with their kids wishes
and um this is why you're supposed to be
parents
and um you know it's like i don't know i
had one guy call me for missing he said
my daughter told me she's going to this
expensive school what am i going to do
and i said well you messed up a long
time ago because my daughter didn't tell
me stuff i tell her stuff that's how
that works so that's where we got
confused we got confused how this works
got confused as to who's in charge here
by the way it's my money
so um of course she's trying to make a
decision
you know reasonably and i'm and i'm not
picking on your kid your kid's obviously
a special child in a lot of good ways uh
and that that's all fine but it does not
mean he's wise
and uh so his
opinion about the connections is
something he heard
from somebody or read
with an internet article
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage ashley's here hey ashley
how are you hi how are you welcome
welcome good to have you so you're here
to do a debt-free scream yeah how much
have you paid off 68 808 good for you
and how long did that take two years
good for you and your range of income
during that time um started out about 65
and then got up to about 90 92. wow what
do you do for a living i'm a teacher
good good what do you teach um i teach
esl hmm english is a second language
excellent what kind of debt was the 69
000 i just had two loans i had my car
and then my student loans
how much was the student loan so my car
was only 10 and the rest of it was all
student loans so um my gosh 59 000 in
student loans yeah all right how long
you been out of school uh
2012. okay so 10 years yeah all right
what happened two years ago that lit you
up girl
um so i went on vacation actually with
my sister and we went to visit our aunt
and uncle and cousins and she was asking
him about like financial advice and i
wasn't really paying attention i um
you know i thought it was fine that was
normal and then um you were normal yeah
he threw out a bunch of different names
and he's like you just have to choose a
philosophy of what you want to do and
how you're going to live with your money
and then um you know research it and
kind of get involved in it so he threw
out one he threw out your name and um
like i said i wasn't paying attention
so a couple months later um i was
actually walking my dog and pandora ad
comes up and it's your podcast
um
yeah so
i was like oh that's that's who he was
talking about so i listened and i was
terrified because i was completely
ignorant i didn't understand anything
that you were saying
so
a different language to you yeah i
wasn't doing a very good job explaining
it but it was just because i had no idea
of anything with financials i just you
know paid i got my paycheck paid my debt
and then went on to groceries and
everything
yeah and then that was it there was
nothing you know it was paycheck to
paycheck
so um then i kept listening kept
listening and i was learning more and
more and then i decided that you know
september comes
because i don't get a paycheck over the
summer so um september comes and i
decided i wanted to start the plan and i
did september 9th and then i paid off my
last bill september 9th of this year wow
exactly two years yes good for you
so you went from not knowing what we
were talking about to actually executing
the plan for two years yes
good for you i learned a lot good for
you yeah you feel confident now
yeah better yeah at least i know where
to get the answers now so if i still
have a question i know where to go okay
that's good yeah that's good and you
chose a philosophy
yes i guess the pandora ads what did it
the
yeah
that's pretty cool yeah if it wasn't for
that you may not get plugged into this
stuff but you went from knowing nothing
to then just doing this plan and paying
it off so you know more than you think
you do clearly so it's funny because if
you ask my family they would say i was
good with money but
i'm just naturally a saver so
i don't really spend a lot of money um
but
i just didn't know what to do with what
i had so like i didn't have any
investments i didn't have anything so
now that i'm on baby step three i'm
almost done um you know i'm working with
my
smart investor and
getting that all set up wow this is
impressive and you realize that it's 20
knowledge 80 behavior and that's why you
only needed a little bit of knowledge
what you needed was the plan then you
needed to commit to the plan yeah and
that's exactly what you did you are very
impressive
very cool proud of you thank you who was
your biggest cheerleader along the way
uh my family they don't necess they
didn't necessarily know what i was like
i was doing the dave ramsey plan in the
beginning um but they knew that uh
paying off the doubt was important to me
and they were very very supportive with
it that's very cool yeah so very good
now they know all about the dave ramsey
plan i can't stop talking about it i
love it that's good well that's your
uncle he got you started so there you go
yeah that's fun i'm proud of you very
well done very very well done you're a
hero
good stuff what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is you're
successful you paid off 69
000 in debt congress can't even balance
their budget
so um the thing for me that was that was
hard was because i only had the two
debts and i paid off my car relatively
quickly and then
it was just one big loan sticking
through it yeah yuck so um stuck in a
hole and like i kind of stalled out a
little bit in the middle just because
you yeah i never had the snowball
because it was just the one just a big
old yeah yeah
so accountability charts was huge for me
like i downloaded like debt-free charts
and i would put it on my fridge and
color it in and then um you know when i
would get to certain levels i made sure
that i would celebrate that and would
you know give myself some sort of reward
for yeah you got to do something to get
truck yeah human mind needs to see
progress yeah so that's a game
yeah this is brilliant you've got it it
says dress it's like tetris but it's a
debt-free chart that you color in
that's fabulous and that i actually
started when because that's only about
like 35 000. that i started halfway
through when i found like that i was
really slowing down and was kind of
losing the motivation so that wasn't
even
the full amount but like still i framed
it and yeah absolutely i would you need
to keep it because it changed you
changed your life uh not because
necessarily you got rid of the debt but
you just took control of your life yeah
instead of just letting things happen to
you you started happening to them yeah
that was yeah that was the big part
you're an impressive young woman very
well done very very well done very cool
very cool so what was hard about this
they're getting stuck in the middle yeah
and just before i had the chart and
before i would kind of do the
celebrations i would be like go go go um
and then you know i was very gazelle
intense but um you know having to have
you know even if it was like going out
to a restaurant you know when i hit a
level on that chart or you know
something like that ordering in you know
something you paid off 35 000 a year
average making making 65. i mean that's
and that's beans and rice well i i got
up to about 92. and that's because of
tutoring i was tutoring every day how
much did you make tutoring um probably
about 15. thousand yeah so what were you
making an hour
uh i do about 60 an hour 60 an hour yeah
in new york and that's low in new york
yeah yeah that's a good thing so yeah
great side job
what are you tutoring in esl esl reading
social studies whatever whatever they
need elementary okay oh anything in
elementary and so just line up and you
probably stay booked up can't you yeah i
would there was in the middle of it i
was doing at least three
or four clients a day so after school
after school yeah working full-time and
then doing that yeah yeah wow now
60 bucks an hour man i know lawyers
don't make that
good for you they're not good lawyers
clearly
i'm cutting you're a great lawyer but
yeah
yeah that's amazing so that that's
really that's what you do right there
yeah so teachers
number three
most likely career to become a
millionaire
out there engineer engineers we found
the most in our millionaire study
accountant was second and teachers were
third
uh entrepreneurs and middle managers
fourth and lawyers there they are fifth
they made it fairly teachers actually
have a higher probability of becoming
millionaires than lawyers yeah teachers
have a head on their shoulders that's
why lawyers are out spending themselves
like crazy well there's that there's
that but you will get there you don't
have to hope if you just keep following
this plan like you have been look at you
the budget is huge like every like even
coming down here everything that we did
um just put it into every dollar and
keep track because then you see you know
where your money is going i had no idea
and there was so much once i did the
budget i was like oh wow i actually have
kind of margin here yeah i mean all
right
where was it all going where was it all
going yeah i feel like you got a raise
yeah pretty impressive we've got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story to
become a baby steps millionaire how
ordinary people build extraordinary
wealth and how you can too also copy a
total money makeover so you can disturb
someone's life with it that you love and
tell them this is what i did you can go
do this and you can win too you're an
impressive lady thank you so much for
making a trip all the way from new york
we appreciate you being here
all right ashley from smithtown new york
69 000 paid off in two years making 65
bumping it up to 92 with the tutor
action count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one i'm
debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it
well done well done kiddo
that's impressive that is impressive i
gotta tell you man you got a teacher out
there tutoring things real i need to go
get tutoring dave that's a good gig
it's not a bad gig at all this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day second
corinthians 4 8 and 9 we are hard
pressed on every side but not crushed
perplexed but not in despair persecuted
but not abandoned struck down but not
destroyed
desmond tutu said hope is being able to
see that there is light
despite
all the darkness
talitha is with us in nashville hi
talitha welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up in your world
well we my husband and i are in our
mid-30s we are on saving for college and
paying off the house early baby steps
but we've had an issue with our van door
not wanting to open so it's in the shop
today
i don't know how much this is going to
cost but my question is depending on the
cost would it be wiser to pull that
money from our emergency savings a
thousand dollars or
not put into our private retirement we
do our
matches with our companies but then we
the server the extra to get up to 15 we
do on our own and i didn't know which
bucket to pull that money from for this
van fix that we need
i mean this is an emergency right
it is so i'm going with the emergency
fund i'm not touching the retirement are
you saying pull money out of the retail
no she's saying don't put it in just
don't don't invest and use that money to
pay for it
i mean right so we would still do our
employer stuff but what we do privately
at the end of the month to meet 15
instead of putting that in our private
account do we use it to pay
for the van i would just continue
investing as you guys are do the full 15
you've got the money in the emergency
fund so cash flow this and then you're
going to fill that emergency fund back
up really quickly and you can still be
investing you guys have the margin to do
that right and baby steps four through
six
right yeah
that's what i would do so uh how much is
in your emergency fund
we have a thousand dollars in our
emergency fund and in our three to six
months that extension we have about
twenty thousand you have two different
accounts no supposed to be combined by
now so now you have 21 000 in your
emergency fund right okay and so what is
the uh repair do you guess yeah i know
you don't know exactly yet but what are
you thinking i'm hoping it's under a
thousand that would be real great but it
would be awesome if it was only around
500.
so we'll see they'll let us know
hopefully but if the whole world comes
to an end it's 2 000 out of 20 000.
right right and um
you guys household income is what
um combined income is about 140 000 okay
and so if your target is 20 000
and you use a thousand out of your 21 we
cut could just leave it alone at 20
right
yeah or you could read
if your target is 20 if your target is
21
and you drop it down to 20
then you just budget you know whatever
it takes over a few months and build it
back up to the 21 target out of your
cash flow out of your budget but this
george is right this is an emergency
this is why you have it a and a an
emergency fund turns an emergency
into an inconvenience
and the very fact that you were asking
this question
says that it did what it was supposed to
do because
you're actually not panicking about this
you just kind of have this intellectual
decision about which way you're going to
do it so it turned it into an
inconvenience instead of an actual
emergency and so as it should so good
good and you make 140 grand you got a
500
possible you need to start saving for a
car
too i don't know what this fan
is what the state of i don't know what
that situation is aaron is in
indianapolis hey aaron what's up
hi dave how are you doing great how can
we help
um so i have a little bit of an issue um
so i purchased a home back in 2020
um
after that my mom actually passed away
from cancer um before that happened
i ended up going tax exempt on my bill
or my uh my check
so
um
i'm sorry you went tax exempt
yes so
um i know that was an issue but i did
that because i needed the extra money to
help her out i mean you quit taking
taxes out of your check you just didn't
withhold anything correct
you had that option at your work
yes
okay
that's weird so i did that um prior to
doing that i had some issues with
taxes you owe the irs
correct
so the issue uh i owe them 17 000. oh
good lord
so the issue with that was is that i had
back taxes um i used to do my taxes for
me but she didn't do them for like
several years so i paid them back um
before i bought my home
but then everything happened with my mom
so
so now you're 17 in the hole again
right so i have a payment plan with them
right now i pay them 250 a month but i
also have other debt i've got about
fifty thousand dollars outside or
actually i'm sorry fifty thousand with
the irs and what's your what's your
income
uh seventy thousand okay irs is at the
top of that snowball
gotcha that's what i was wondering it's
the top of the tennis snowball because
the penalties and interest are
unbelievably expensive
and they have almost unlimited power to
screw up your life if you miss a payment
on this installment plan
and even if you don't miss a payment on
installment plan and they screw up
because they're incompetent they'll come
clean out all your accounts and go oops
we messed up
and they do that kind of stuff
accidentally
sometimes so no you want this out of
your life as soon as possible
and please tell me that after messing
with these people two times you're never
going to do this again
absolutely not i have a daughter now and
she is the why behind i'm trying to get
out of debt do you have a tax problem
you're working with
i'm sorry do you have a tax professional
that you're working with
i do not okay this this may be another
solution jump onto ramseysolutions.com
and you can get connected with one of
our trusted elps to help you walk
through this so that you don't have this
giant tax bill ever again never again
set yourself up where you're under the
thumb of these people anyone for that
matter of kind of debt but this is the
worst possible kind of debt and it goes
to the top of your debt snowball
porsche's in houston texas hey portia
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you dave my favorite person
um
i um obsessed with you george i told you
it hurt a little bit i'm not gonna lie
portia but i'm fine george i'm fine
i'll earn your love over time
no jordan you're my favorite one of my
favorites sure okay okay we'll get to
you among the ramsey personalities
george wow
all right portia what you got um
so this is what i have
and basically i'm paying for being
stupid in the past i've i've already
beat myself up okay and i need to climb
out of it so we don't have okay
yeah i made uh i'm a hundred and eleven
thousand dollars in debt eighty-four
percent of that student loans sixteen
percent of that is my car
uh my car i owe seventeen thousand nine
hundred sixty-one in 71 states
um i made in the past
before covent i made 120 000 a year as a
general manager at fitness connection i
ran multiple locations in houston
um
now i'm taking a huge salary cut by
seventy eight thousand i only make forty
two thousand a year now with the same
time
no with a different company they shut
down because they covet on the gyms
they made major changes
i'll just say that we made a lot of
major changes so what are you doing now
i work at the uh uni at my school at the
university of houston downtown um i'm in
grad school
uh and i'm getting my mba in finance and
also investment management
since being in my mba program and
learning from you i've just learned so
much about following the math pretty
much
and so now that i'm calculating
everything i'm just kicking myself when
are you finishing all this and going to
get back into the 120 range
well actually i've been taking out
grants and scholarships
when are you finishing all of this and
gonna get back into the 120 income range
all this nba and school stuff
you're right uh summer 2023 i'll be
finished
but
here's the there's a caveat um i've
actually received um
corporate finance certifications and
approaching an internship
um
for uh to get experience yeah what is
your income gonna be there
um i'll be making i'll be in the six
figure range oh good okay so then you
can start knocking this out right
yeah so you don't suggest that i should
start knocking it out now i start
knocking it out now but you can't knock
it out now at 48 like you can knock it
out when you're making 100.
so i was trying to get your income up
that's where this conversation was going
and you're already ahead of me you
already got a plan which i'm glad to
hear
you've got a lot of stuff going on in
your brain uh make sure your brain takes
you to tactical answers that cause money
to come into your wallet because you
have a good brain and you're using it
but it needs to cause money to come into
your wallet and then pay these bills
that's how this works george campbell
good show thanks man appreciate it
what's this hour the ramsey showing the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately one only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
with the principal
did you know the ramsay show is one of
the most popular podcasts in the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you